salut jek je peux avoir une grande
bouteille de bijoux tu sais quoi des
balances mois deux grandes bouteilles
oui parce que demain est incertain
affirmatif mon pote je me plaignais
d'avoir à subir tous les jours la même
chose maintenant chaque matin c'est
pareil sérieusement chaussures pompanon
tulle embrouilles
tout bascule ok quelqu'un veut un café
j'ai pas comment c'est possible
je continue à revivre la même journée
désolé mon grand
chaque fois que je vois ce qui est
arrivé à mon appartement
je peux pas m'empêcher de penser je
n'arriverai jamais à récupérer ma
caution
sap a toujours été comme ça il y avait
une femme que je n'ai été magnifique
un fils que j'aime maintenant une bande
de connards ne bute encore et encore je
meurs jour après jour
si jamais la capacité de réécrire
l'histoire était bien réel
et si nous pouvions y passer tout mon
erreur
prototype nous donne le pouvoir de dieu
grand rien mon fils je vais revenir pour
toi comment je peux arrêter tout ça
djemaa il ne s'agit pas de l'arrêter
mais plutôt de le relancer
c'est exact une fois passée la stupeur
je veux que ça s'arrête
[Musique]
ils ont une armée entière
moi tout ce que j'ai c'est le temps
je dois apprendre à combattre à l'épée
j'en connais un qui n'a pas chômé
[Musique]
j'attends ce moment depuis très
longtemps pour faire simple la journée